nous connaissons tous la mythologie
tous étaient bercés par ces récits de
victoire héroïque et de tragédies
déchirante et tout ça souvent au milieu
d'un contexte politique extrêmement
complexe et intemporel et d'ailleurs
l'essence même d'un mythe c'est son
intemporalité
c'est la façon dont on peut le
réinterpréter encore et encore et encore
et ça quelle que soit l'époque la
mythologie elle est tellement riche
qu'elle a inspiré de nombreux domaines
par exemple en littérature il ya
beaucoup d'auteurs qui ils doivent leur
brillante carrière à la mythologie
grecque par exemple il n'ya pas qu'en
littérature qu'on peut observer le
potentiel fictionnel d'un mythe est
aussi dans l'industrie en l'occurrence
et le mythe auquel j'aimerais vous
sensibiliser aujourd'hui c'est celui de
l'aérotrain l'aérotrain c'était une
navette dans les années 70 il
fonctionner sur un monorail en béton
grâce à une sustentation par coussin
d'air et qui pouvaient atteindre la
vitesse de 400 km heure et ça j'insiste
bien dans les années 70 le l'ingénieur
jean bertin était le père de l'aérotrain
et depuis lors je vais pas revenir sur
l'histoire de l'aérotrain bien sûr mais
il subsiste encore quelques traces dont
je vais vous parler ce soit alors on a
repris dès 2017 ce mythe de l'aérotrain
en essayant de voir ce qu'il pouvait
être amélioré est ce qu'on pouvait en
faire pour l'adapter à la société
d'aujourd'hui voir ce que les 50 années
de progrès technologique entre les
années 70 et aujourd'hui pouvait nous
apporter pour améliorer l'aérostat on
est donc installée en région centre val
de loire on s'est mis quitte à petit a
cherché toutes les traces de l'aérotrain
en suis rendu compte que ces cinquante
années avait éparpillé vraiment tout ce
qu'on aurait pu trouver pour nous aider
à redémarrer ce projet là toutes les
traces presque parce qu'en région centre
val de loire au nord d'orléans
précisément il reste un monorail de
béton de 20 km de long est en
relativement bon état et ce monorail la
selle c'est un objet nitot logique en
lui même sur cet édifice hors norme
l'auteur philippe vasset écrit dans son
récit une vie en l'air dans le train qui
me ramenait de paris
je plaque est la tête contre la vitre
pour voir pendant quelques précieuses
minutes
le monument dessinées de longs
mouvements reptilien ses arches se
succédaient sous l'effet de la vitesse
comme si l'immense squelette déplié ses
vertèbres et lever la tête avant de
partir en chasse voilà donc à ces mots
de philippe vasset vous sentez vous
aussi il imagine tout le potentiel
mythologique de cet édifice là alors cet
édifice on est très tôt rentrer en
contact avec les autorités de la région
du loiret pour voir quelles solutions
pouvaient exister afin qu'on le récupère
et qu'on en fasse une piste d'essai
exactement finalement comme l'ingénieur
jean bertin dans les années 70 et en se
faisant connaître de des autorités de la
région et des locaux beaucoup de
passionnés ont émergé et ont souhaité
contribuer à notre projet en mettant à
notre service au service de ce projet là
toutes les connaissances qu'ils avaient
pu accumuler pendant 50 ans certains
d'entre eux avaient même pu monter dans
l'aéroport est en petit lors des essais
de l'ingénieur jean bertin d'autres
avaient même été des proches de
l'ingénieur voilà toute cette matière là
elle a pu faire avancer le projet pour
le point où on en est aujourd'hui
al'inverse et j'en arrive à la première
leçon qu'on a tiré de cette aventure là
certains de ces passionnés est
extrêmement réfractaires au changement
et la première leçon de cette aventure
c'est que quand on reprend un mythe
on doit s'attendre à déranger certaines
personnes parce que quand je lui ai dit
au départ un mythe un vrai caractère
interprétatif
et selon la façon dont on l'interprète
on peut déranger certaines personnes il
n'empêche que pour rester très
pragmatique il fallait changer
l'aérotrain l'hérault train ils posaient
les problèmes de nuisances sonores il
posait des problèmes de confort
voyageurs également il posait des
problèmes de pollution aujourd'hui tout
ça c'est des choses auxquelles on fait
énormément attention dans le
développement des innovations
d'ailleurs on a pu décliner trois
priorités stratégiques sur le
développement de notre space train la
première c'était produire un transport
plus rapide que ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui la deuxième de produire un
transport propre et bien sûr la
troisième à un coût réduit puisqu'il ne
sert à rien d'innover
si l'innovation ne parle pas à la
plupart des gens dès 2018
on a travaillé notre ancrage local donc
en région centre val de loire en ouvrant
notre premier laboratoire destiné à la
construction des prototypes au bord de
ce monorail là parallèlement on
continuer nos échanges avec la région de
façon à pouvoir récupérer ce monorail
mais d'une certaine façon nos demandes
n'étaient pas forcément prise en compte
et relayée au bon endroit dans un
premier temps néanmoins on avait quand
même beaucoup de soutien aux régions
centre val de loire il souhaite leur
rendre hommage aujourd'hui je crois que
les premiers soutiens de space train
c'est vraiment les médias et d'abord les
médias locaux qui ont su s'intéresser à
ce projet là et en étant sensibles à
tout le potentiel qu'il pouvait ramener
à la région et surtout à cet édifice qui
était abandonné depuis 50 ans grâce à
ces médias des portes se sont ouvertes
et des oreilles se mirent à nous écouter
et laura en région centre val de loire
qu'on a eu on la doit principalement au
mythe de l'aérotrain qui relaie encore
cette formidable épopée sur sur le
projet se restreint comporte aujourd'hui
est la deuxième
la deuxième leçon qu'on tire de cette
aventure c'est que quand on récupère un
mythe quand on essaie de construire sur
un mythe finalement il faut vraiment en
définir en identifier les principaux
symboles et essayer dévaloriser ses
symboles là en l'occurrence c'est ce
qu'on a essayé de faire avec le monorail
depuis qu'on s'est lancé en 2018 l'année
2018 comme je vous le disais on était
très favorable en termes d'ancrage local
des premiers soutiens autre que les
médias se sont se sont montrés les
structures éducatives par exemple de la
région souhaitez nous rejoindre en nous
apportant énormément on a renforcé notre
équipe également de trois docteurs et le
projet a été lancé ont décliné les
différentes briques technologiques dans
notre laboratoire c'est à dire les
coussins d'air de façon à maintenir la
navette en sustentation éviter tout
frottement les moteurs linéaires pour
propulser la navette et bien sûr le
système de gestion d'énergie à base
d'une pile à hydrogène pour produire une
être potentiellement zéro émission ce
projet là qui était assez important
grâce à ses torts à qu'on a eu en région
centre val de loire en local on a pu
être beaucoup plus serein quand on a
abordé la dimension nationale en effet
grâce à tout ce que je vous ai expliqué
on a pu aborder la dimension nationale
avec beaucoup plus de sérénité et
surtout rencontrer un maximum de
personnes cette fois ci à l'échelle du
territoire national qui ont pu faire
avancer le projet comment là comme on
l'entendait et ça ne m'amène à la
troisième leçon qu'on tire de ce projet
là grâce à cette aura nationale
maintenant on est dépassé au niveau
supérieur on a pu recevoir le
mathématicien cédric villani dans notre
laboratoire avec qui toute l'équipe a eu
des échanges extrêmement passionnées et
sincère je crois qu'il était sincèrement
intéressé par notre projet et en partant
il nous a donné un dernier conseil nous
a dit souvenez-vous que l'innovation est
importante mais que le modèle économique
n'est peut-être davantage
effectivement ça nous a fait méditer ça
nous a fait également ça nous a rassurés
puisque dans les priorités stratégiques
qu'on s'était fixé dès le départ c'est à
dire de produire un transport rapide et
propre certes mais surtout bien plus
abordable que ce qui se fait aujourd'hui
on était raccord avec ce que nous a
indiqué cédric villani le projet
avançait bien en 2018 on a développé nos
principaux composants qu'on est encore
actuellement d'eux en train de tester
aujourd'hui à votre laboratoire et
l'année 2019 pour le coup nous a fait
entrer dans une dimension cette fois-ci
internationale et pour une petite équipe
de 15 personnes comme nous rentrer dans
une dimension internationale et
finalement se confronter à nos
concurrents qui sont des mastodontes
au fond presque illimitées finalement
c'est quelque chose de très puissant et
de très important et finalement ce qui
était compliqué sur la scène
internationale en 2019 c'est de ne pas
entrer dans le jeu de la guerre de
communication que se livraient les
autres concurrents on pouvait voir dans
les médias par exemple que un concurrent
communiquer sur sa vitesse à 750 km
heure quinze jours plus tard à l'aube ou
de l'europe
vous aviez un autre qui annonçait 900 km
heure et puis de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique un mois après on dépassait
et demi kilomètre
incroyable cette guerre de communication
a touché aussi d'autres aspects par
exemple et pas le moindre
l'empreinte carbone de ses solutions là
et là encore on pouvait s'apercevoir
qu'ils avaient beaucoup d'hypocrisie
dans la communication d'autres
concurrents par exemple quand on nous on
a commencé à communiquer sur le fait
qu'on utilise à hydrogène et qu'on était
capable de proue de sortir un transport
propre d'autres concurrents ont dit ah
oui mais nous aussi enfin un bon ça va
pas non plus on pollue pas tant que ça
et tout est en réalité si cet argument
là il faut vraiment qu en tant que
public vous ne vous lui attacher
d'importance et que vous soyez
extrêmement précis avec les termes
employés dans la communication
environnementale parce que décarbonés ne
veut pas forcément dire en train de
carbone neutre etc
et je trouve que on est nombreux en tout
cas à ne pas ne pas forcément faire le
distinctif le troisième aspect bien sûr
sur lequel tout le monde jouait et à
propos duquel j'ai pu lire des articles
absolument lunaire sur nos concurrents
étaient le fait de sortir un transport
abordable
j'en ai trouvé un quand même dans les
médias qui a réussi à sortir que sa
solution serait gratuite alors que
souvenez vous des paroles de l'oracle
pas d'innovation sans modèle économique
solide
c'est vraiment ça qu'il faut essayer de
retenir quoi qu'il en soit en voyant
tous ces aspects là la quatrième leçon
aussi con qu'on sait qu'on sait donner
c'est de respecter les valeurs du mythe
qu'on reprenait et en l'occurrence les
retraites est pétri de bons sens tout ce
qui a été sorti sur les retraites est
pétri de bons sens et c'est aussi ce
qu'on a essayé de reprendre à travers
les points qu'on s'est imposé
en l'occurrence une navette donc qui
circulent sur des coussins d'air et qui
est abordable parce que bien sûr on ne
peut pas proposer un transport plus cher
que ce qui existe aujourd'hui et c'est
grâce à ces valeurs là qui nous ont été
transmises par l'aérotrain ce qui nous a
été inspirée qu'on a pu décliner la
lettre space train qui sera destinée aux
marchés de lignes interurbaines et qui
ne concurrencera pas les grandes lignes
de tgv qui fonctionne très bien
aujourd'hui
voilà c'est en ça qu'on a construit sur
le mythe de l'aérotrain en s'inspirant
de ses valeurs en s'inspirant en
s'appropriant également ses symboles et
en écoutant les passionnés qui pendant
50 ans avait remis un petit peu ce
projet là et qui sont avec nous
aujourd'hui pour le faire revivre
voilà comment est ce qu'on a finalement
à travers ça créé notre propre mythe
merci
[Applaudissements]